a special moment tonight as a group of  teens and adults take their new jobs  into the  rather new skills into the job market so  it's our hope that  these students will take the knowledge  that we gave them and begin to enter the  workforce and find a stem career that  really suits them and their needs  help of southern nevada partnering with  desert research institute to train  six students in the stem force program  for the last month those students got  hands-on  nasa research solar car races then  learned how to apply it to the real  world  the desert research institute says about  70 percent of jobs today  are stem related science technology  engineering and math